[Music]
in underlying message news submitted by
david needs love to a survey finds that
christmas gifts are often used to send
passive-aggressive messages I could kind
of see that yeah
yeah like you smell like [ __ ] that's in
the car like in the workplace where
people do like like gift giving yeah and
then like political gifts like your you
don't really want to [ __ ] do it but
then you do it cuz it's just like that
kind of world you know yeah political
gifts like you didn't if you have a big
family to like there's people that you
don't really want to give [ __ ] - but
then appearances and stuff yeah
appearance and all that you just got to
give things to them you know like and we
don't live in that world but it's a it's
a it's a pretty big natural thing out
there like in the human habitat like
people had to deal with that [ __ ] all
the time
that's true yeah you try to get that job
from ocean you gotta give it your
manager maybe yep what are them up a
little bit yeah yeah like you can't just
give everybody a gift and not give it to
one person yeah
or you can and you can be
passive-aggressive exactly it's like I'm
gonna give you something but watch it
certainly a look about how to lose
weight in the new year's oh [ __ ] and
smelvin
yeah son of a [ __ ] yeah so a study
conducted by one poll on behalf of back
blade which is a body grooming company
as 2000 Americans about Christmas gifts
and they found it was that many back
here it's a shaving company because I've
seen them it's like a back scratcher but
like I see that very very bad cut
yourself know like not a thing it's like
you know like a like a guys Mach three
type now that doesn't sound okay know if
it's like you know you know if you go
slow guard cuz I pictured a shaving for
your back and I was thinking it just
made me go what do guys with back here
do yeah I just let it grow until I know
I'm about to go out to the beach and I'm
like a key shaving your core you have
someone that will help you shape yeah oh
yeah but yeah if I don't
I back her oh I'm a wolf dude really I'm
a walking our neck doesn't look wolfy it
doesn't start it starts like right here
nothing you see it oh yeah my mom will
always be it's funny though because it
was like each at you aren't you warm all
the time yeah pretty much
my like you see fuzz when I was younger
but didn't like once I got like 20 you
hit puberty 200 some like that
everywhere well here in here you are
like I'm a [ __ ] man my boss finally
but when he does it's too much that's
tight
you're a chia pet so yeah anytime it's
like every time I'm like oh we about to
go out somewhere all right hey keep
shaving because I'm not trying to go out
would you be down a wax or laser she
told you that but that's all the expense
of that and I was like I'm cool I'll
deal with it it's like a one-time
expense you're not to worry about the
laser is it a multiple laser a wax I
like I can't go back really painful like
with laser existing I don't know why
anyone want a wax would they handle guys
to gather know they have a lot of guy
could get my ass [ __ ] lasered off
yeah your groin area everything I just
don't want to stand and spread my cheeks
got this [ __ ] laser thing and they're
like spread your butt cheeks mmm no oh
like they tell you to hold it yourself
so you state your leg gap yes you turn
around you do think this does it hurt
why they're so lazy why don't they hold
your budget yeah it's a full service
leave the [ __ ] lazy what about the
other hand no they got
it's okay if they've got a laser that
kills the tattoo artists they spread
with one hand they just did yeah but
they they need to like stretch the skin
out be sexual harassment they're like
you know what hold your own let's do it
yourself man that's cheaper than new
there'll be some ladies that like
spreads the lips and stuff and then
other times they'll be like can you have
an edge there to get my balls lasered
cuz if it hurts no not if not like to
have your hair is I think I'll say how
thick your balls are oh I can't get to
it man they're just too much of all
skins kind of thick you know what about
numbing pain there's no no variance does
it work you feel it I've never used it
why would you want to put an onion cream
on your ass in balls so when they zap it
it doesn't work no but then what if you
can't feel it anymore
I think you know we're off I'm pretty
sure it'll wear off in two dentists Joe
having them do your mouth all right so
back to these gifts here all right
the laser doesn't numb your privates no
oh thank god cuz I I'm very sensitive
minors I like my nerves for sure you'll
have your nerves it's like if this is
your your hair follicles yeah it like
burns it to the the root so then that's
me and then like your hair follicles
start getting smaller yes we have to go
in sessions because in like then it
won't grow as thick and then I get
smaller again and then all that [ __ ] and
then a bite
what's gonna happen this this year I'm
gonna get a shaver I'm gonna get
manscaping for Monica no no I mean for
me should get it for me that's seven
like you I thought you're buying it that
was her passes I'm you know our
passive-aggressive
gift like here's some manscape here's
some shaver like deal with that goes
back blade certificate to get wax
they're not like them lasered
Brandi over there yeah so they're saying
that a lot of the people give take the
hint gifts so like what we mentioned
before it's like if someone smells bad
they'll give like deodorant or cologne
or if they have bad breath they'll give
a fancy toothbrush
so then they found that 26% of men were
saying that they planned on giving a
take take the hint gift and 17% of women
said they would do this type of gift so
it's more likely that men would do it
dudes are more passive aggressive with
the gift giving yep that's why we do the
survey I want to know in this survey if
the dudes are doing it to their wives so
they have to do something clever like
that like the [ __ ] peloton because
you could ever want to ride a bike in
the living room but yeah so then they
said the survey also revealed that only
56 percent of Americans are worried
about giving the perfect gift
well 46 percent are worried about giving
a gift that makes them look cheap
other popular get worried about yeah
other popular take a hint gifts are like
cookbooks exercise equipment cleaning
supplies gym memberships and alarm clock
consumer sip is a big one too yeah yeah
people worry about alarm clocks yeah I
mean like these pasta I've never given
and I don't think I don't think I've
ever received a passive-aggressive okay
well that's it we don't live in this
world yeah well I needed this alarm
clock read like you're late ass she's
always [ __ ] late she got me shoes
clean everybody's myself Oh like I don't
buy shoes for ten years of time whoa she
was elastic ten years
yeah then as long as you ever one thing
there's one I had where I was like I am
mostly sitting actually if I think about
it um
and then like I'll have like I had a
hole in one of my vans like that
actually my my toe poked I was like okay
now it's time and that would be time you
buy shoes you go look at all the
technological advances versions of van
slip-ons every time okay actually
upgrade this ones I have they actually
when I went they were like oh we've a
pro version now oh so yeah I guess it
isn't you tiger they I'm a pro but
thicker it's a little bigger and
actually is more comfortable that she
saw yeah yeah exactly it sound like oh
cool thank you I'll come back in ten
years we got we got a stinky ass friend
though that we've spoken to multiple
times yeah and
I can see everybody getting together and
giving him this all day or something a
spa day a makeover soap lifetime showers
like a washing machine dryer detergent
softener a whole department I could see
all that happening out of the goodness
of the hearts of others in the in the
goodness of their noses yeah yeah
goodness so their noses being the
primary line is everyone's selfish yeah
no matter what good did they do this
they're always an underlying selfish
reason this country I'm so lucky I can't
smell this friend yeah I think that's
why I had hunches why during some though
don't be so specific whenever we're
whenever we're all together and we go on
field trips they always assign me next
to this person the one that could bear
it yeah yeah I mean to be fit I don't
even I don't smell that person either
I'm the same as you like I've heard it
I'm like really
I've never experienced it before but
then that also worries me that something
might be up with you cuz like I smell so
bad that I can't even I'm not you and
let you know if I can't smell this
person do I smell you're concerned about
your nostril it's just burning yeah like
that whole sense I don't care about mine
oh nice one I don't want to know people
I think Kara feels like it's like being
color blind this foods like nose blind
yeah could be a there's like certain
levels that there's frequencies that
just does not connect in his nose yeah
has to be that extreme Breanna I smell
my own fart I'm like someone's not gonna
like this was in the store oh my girl
funding's targets him like that and I
went to a different aisles so that I
could fart and then she was like she
kept coming closer and ask me questions
about like towels like that and then she
snowed it and I was like I specifically
went away from you so you would not
smell things yeah
Rodopi oh yeah like what I farted
appreciate that your than walking into
it
that was a passive-aggressive guess that
you do I'll do that [ __ ] all the time
man like you how you want a way to be
discreet and you screamed it on oh yeah
I've never smelled it smell
I know yeah they do and I'm like I think
you took a [ __ ] no and then I go to and
I'm like did you poop it goes no and I'm
like yes you did
can I go check his diaper I'm like oh
I'm sorry baby did it did you just you
just hear it in the diaper it sounds
funny because I like oh when did you
guys stop doing traditional gift-giving
what's the traditional mean what's Boyd
what's a new AG gift giving New Age is I
feel like you're not so material Oh or
like the new school of thought is like
you're not really well like traditional
gift-giving would be like for every
special occasion within your group of
friends you guys do get something and
you exchange like like a Christmas
everyone does that for your family or
whatever right I do whatever you're with
you yeah yeah some people keep it up I
think and some people don't
I think I'll like give gifts if I'm
going actively to someone's like
Christmas dinner or like if it's a group
somewhere yeah you're gonna be
exchanging for you out of my way and be
like I'm gonna go across now to give you
this unless I like got invited to
something right I'm the only dude I'm
inspired like it's not a mandatory every
year you do it well I'm like the last
gift I got last gift I gave that's true
this group was maybe I remember I gave
Casey and Jo sunglasses those Oakley's
but that was no festivity I was like no
cuz I was like oh I'm Asian I have a
small bridge i'ma buy some sunglasses
and hours as I was buying them as a oh
you know love's got small bridges
no good so I just got use it for
snowboarding yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
and I lost it somewhere
[Music]